Trascrizione: Martynka Quaglio
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Briano Martinoni: Quanti, fra voi,
nell'osservare i cambiamenti climatici,
si sentono frustrati
dall'incapacità di agire,
di potere fare qualcosa di concreto oggi?
Quanti fra voi sono stanchi
di aspettare l'azione di governi,
organizzazioni internazionali
che negli ultimi trent'anni
hanno promesso tantissimo,
ma che ci lasciano oggi
un presente più povero,
dove migliaia di specie,
tra animali e piante, si sono già estinte
e tante altre rischiano di diventarlo?
Quanti, fra voi,
hanno voglia di fare qualcosa
per cambiare questa situazione,
ma magari non sanno come
perché non sanno come navigare
le migliaia di soluzioni disponibili,
o peggio ancora non si fidano di esse?
Cioè, perché spesso,
quando facciamo una donazione,
non riusciamo a capire esattamente
come vengano spesi i nostri soldi,
e l'impatto che hanno in modo specifico.
Ovviamente, lo sappiamo tutti,
ciascuno può fare la sua parte
nella lotta ai cambiamenti climatici,
cambiando il proprio stile di vita.
Quando prendiamo la macchina -
quando prendiamo la bici,
anziché la macchina,
quando andiamo in vacanza vicino casa,
anziché prendere un aereo,
stiamo riducendo la nostra
impronta carbonica.
Ma per quanto ci impegniamo
a fare la nostra parte
per portare questo numero
il più vicino possibile allo zero,
continuiamo ad essere parte del problema.
Bene, il nostro sogno è di dare a tutti
la possibilità di passare dall'altro lato,
di diventare parte della soluzione,
di avere un ruolo attivo, e non passivo,
nella lotta ai cambiamenti climatici.
Prima di raccontarvi esattamente
quello che fa "Green Future Project",
voglio raccontarvi
la storia di come è nato,
perché qui stanno i nostri valori.
All'inizio del 2020,
poco prima che scoppiasse la pandemia,
mi trovavo in Amazzonia,
a filmare un documentario
sulla rapida deforestazione
di alcune aree di questa zona.
Eravamo in Ecuador: un francese,
un americano e un italiano.
Sembra una barzelletta,
ma vi giuro che non lo è.
Eravamo lì, seguendo una di queste strade
aperte da una compagnia di deforestazione.
Sono strade strane,
perché si avventurano sempre più
nel cuore dell'Amazzonia.
Eppure, anche se non portano
da nessuna parte,
da esse continuano a uscire camion enormi,
carichi di giganti ormai morti,
con la resina che ancora
scende fresca dai tronchi.
A un certo punto ci dobbiamo fermare,
perché sul ciglio della strada
vediamo questo.
Lo vedete: sul tronco c'è scritto,
"Se vende, 50 $".
Vendono per 50 dollari
l'albero più alto che abbiamo visto
in due settimane di riprese,
un gigante alto 60 metri.
Allora scattiamo una foto,
la mettiamo sui social;
e subito centinaia di persone ci scrivono,
ci chiedono di comprare l'albero,
ci dicono che lo vogliono proteggere,
ci vogliono dare una mano,
perciò lo compriamo.
Il problema è che poi iniziano i problemi,
perché la gente prima paga e poi pretende.
E giustamente, pretendevano di sapere
che quell'albero sarebbe stato protetto
negli anni a venire, nel futuro.
Perciò andiamo a parlare
con una comunità locale, che vive lì,
e per una piccola fee annuale
si impegnano a proteggere l'albero,
si impegnano a proteggerlo e dimostrarci
che lo stanno proteggendo,
mandandoci una foto, una foto ogni mese.
Perciò, di questo gruppo di persone,
ciascuno di noi riceve quella foto.
Bene, io da questa storia ho imparato
tre lezioni fondamentali.
La prima è che ci sono
migliaia di persone, là fuori,
che hanno voglia di essere
parte della soluzione,
ma non sanno come,
ma soprattutto che dobbiamo fornirgli
soluzioni semplici e trasparenti.
50 dollari per un albero,
in quel caso ci aiuta un graffiti artist
nell'Amazzonia, come avete visto.
La seconda è che, in quanto esseri umani,
siamo più inclini a essere emozionati
per quello che sentiamo vicino,
per ciò che possiamo toccare con mano.
Perciò, prima di chiedere a qualcuno,
dall'altro lato del mondo,
di darci dei soldi
per proteggere qualcosa,
dobbiamo prima creare un filo connettore
tra la persona e il progetto.
La terza, la più importante di tutti:
i migliori protettori
delle nostre cattedrali naturali,
a livello mondiale,
sono le comunità indigene.
Proteggono questi luoghi
da migliaia di anni.
Ad oggi, l'80 percento della biodiversità,
a livello mondiale, è protetta da loro.
Perciò, se vogliamo creare
delle soluzioni durature
dobbiamo farlo con loro.
(Applausi)
Pietro Pasolini: Siamo partiti
proprio da questa esperienza
per cercare di capire
come potevamo valorizzare
il potere di un'azione collettiva.
Abbiamo dato ascolto
alle voci degli scienziati,
con l'obiettivo di cercare di accelerare
la trasformazione
verso un'energia più pulita,
proteggere, riforestare, soprattutto
rigenerare zone ad alta biodiversità,
e capire noi stessi,
come possiamo ridurre il nostro impatto
nella nostra vita di tutti i giorni.
Al mondo di oggi esistono
tantissime soluzioni, ONG, start up
che offrono già soluzioni molto efficienti
nella lotta al cambiamento climatico.
Quello che manca è un connettore,
che raggruppi queste migliori soluzioni
e dia all'utente la massima trasparenza
in termini di soldi spesi
e risultati ottenuti.
Tutto questo, ovviamente, non è facile,
perché non dobbiamo stravolgere
la nostra vita di tutti i giorni.
Altrimenti, quanti di noi
veramente rinuncerebbero?
Senza rinunciare, perché comunque
questa è un'emergenza globale
e abbiamo bisogno che piu gente possibile
sia parte della soluzione.
Ed è proprio qui che il nostro sogno,
la nostra visione, è diventata realtà.
Abbiamo creato una piattaforma,
un connettore emotivo,
democratico ma soprattutto accessibile,
che permette a chiunque di voi,
qua, in pochi istanti,
di prendere ed avere un ruolo attivo,
lo vedete in anteprima,
perché questa è la piattaforma 2.0
che verrà presentata, rilasciata
tra due settimane.
Abbiamo pensato anche
a come dare al dato scientifico
una connotazione più umana,
più vera, più vicina a noi.
Se io stasera vi parlassi
solo di tonnellate di CO2,
probabilmente l'informazione
passerebbe via,
non lascerebbe nessun effetto.
Se invece vi dico
che questa sera, grazie a voi,
abbiamo deciso di piantare dieci alberi
per ogni presente qua in sala,
l'effetto generato è l'equivalente
di 74 voli da Roma a New York.
(Applausi)
Abbiamo riforestato l'equivalente
di 47.41 campi da tennis.
Direi che fa un effetto
leggermente diverso.
Ed infine, la cosa più importante:
abbiamo cercato di rinforzare
quel legame emotivo che c'è
tra noi e il mondo,
tra noi e quella meravigliosa natura
che ci permette di vivere.
Come?
Imparando a conoscere meglio,
a conoscere le piante, le biodiversità
e gli animali che la vivono.
Tutto questo pensandolo quasi
come se fosse un videogioco,
per giocare tutti insieme
a cambiare il mondo.
BM: A "Green Future Project"
ci viene spesso detto
che siamo dei sognatori;
ed è vero, perché noi pensiamo davvero
che se un gruppo di individui
si mette insieme,
hanno la capacità di riscrivere la Storia.
Ma nel sognare in grande,
perché lo facciamo in grande,
lo facciamo con i numeri alla mano.
Pensate che se noi avessimo
gli stessi utenti -
anzi, non se, quando;
quando noi avremo gli utenti di Netflix,
insieme, in maniera collettiva,
saremo capaci di evitare delle emissioni
o di assorbire l'equivalente
di 1.7 miliardi di tonnellate di CO2.
L'equivalente del 70 % delle emissioni
dell'Unione Europea in un anno.
In più saremmo capaci, sempre in un anno,
di piantare 25 miliardi di alberi,
che ricoprirebbero più o meno
una zona che è un terzo dell'Italia.
Io penso che oggi siamo
ad un crocevia, siamo un bivio.
E in quanto generazione dobbiamo decidere,
abbiamo solo due scelte:
la prima è quella di essere
i colpevoli attivi,
ma soprattutto di aver
passivamente accettato
la distruzione della biodiversità
su questo pianeta.
E poi abbiamo l'altra scelta,
quella di unirci in modo collettivo
e trovare insieme, grazie
al potere della collettività,
una soluzione per riscrivere
quello che sarà il nostro futuro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)